in what I think is a hilarious but also
correct turn of events Roseanne bars
reboot of her sitcom Roseanne has been
canceled by ABC just hours after she
tweeted just a horribly racist string of
messages Roseanne posted a comment
yesterday it feels like it's a week ago
because of how much has happened but
yesterday Roseanne posted a comment
about former Obama advisor Valerie
Valerie Jarrett on Twitter saying Muslim
Brotherhood and Planet of the Apes had a
baby equals VJ meaning Valerie Jarrett
in response to another Twitter comment
about Valerie Jarrett and of course
Valerie Jarrett happens to be black and
Roseanne references monkeys and as usual
her defenders say it's not racist monkey
isn't racist Planet of the Apes isn't
racist it's merely a coincidence that
Valerie Valerie Jarrett is black and
historically there is significant sort
of racist institutional history of
equating black people to monkeys but
it's a mere coincidence and of course
why are the people that are insulted as
monkeys very often black are they saying
it is literally the mere coincidence I'm
sarcastically referencing and Roseanne
later deleted the tweet but it was too
late just hours later ABC cancelled
Roseanne's show they put out a statement
which said in part that quote Rosen's
Twitter statement is abhorrent repugnant
and inconsistent with our values and we
have decided to cancel her show Roseanne
also later apologizing on Twitter saying
I apologized to Valerie Jarrett and to
all Americans I am truly sorry for
making a bad joke about her politics and
her looks I should have known better
forgive me my joke was in bad taste that
was the one of the first apologies later
she said she was tweeting on the sleep
medication ambien saying it was 2:00 in
the morning and I was ambien tweeting of
his Memorial Day - I don't know how
Memorial Day brings out racist statement
when you are on ambien or what the
Canadian connection is and of course
obviously my question was did ambi is
she saying ambien made her racist I mean
I've
take an ambien when I'm traveling to try
to adjust very difficult to fall asleep
with the jetlag when you go to Europe
for example I didn't all of a sudden
think black people were monkeys nor nor
did it occur to me to start tweeting
about it and it is just fascinating for
a few reasons first of all and I'll get
to I know that people are aware that she
has blocked me because of my comments
we'll get to that in a second Roseanne's
reboot made her like a darling of the
right it was rebooted it initially got
great ratings Trump called roseanne to
congratulate her the right hail date is
finally a show just for sort of regular
traditional people despite the fact that
Roseanne is super rich and part Jewish
not the sort of down-home whatever she's
made out to be a good old gal or
whatever let's put that aside and this
has completely imploded in their faces
and I tweeted her about this I've
actually exchanged direct messages and
tweets with Roseanne before I tweeted to
Roseanne after the ambien thing which
we'll put up on the screen for you oh
man this is just the best Roseanne is
now defending her tweets by saying
ambien made her racist and Roseanne
almost immediately responding to me
saying no I didn't I blamed myself stop
lying
yes I have had odd ambien experiences on
tweeting late at night like many other
people do I blame myself okay it's just
an explanation not an excuse okay bully
and then when I went to respond she had
sadly blocked me Roseanne I don't even
know where to start with this right I
mean politically this is a woman who's
off her rocker right she has called
Chelsea Clinton Chelsea Soros Clinton
she said George Soros is trying to
overthrow the US government and she said
that the CIA is funding some kind of
mind-control thing all of this really
really crazy stuff but what I don't
really understand here is if you're not
blaming ambien why do you mention ambien
and if the ambien had a role to play did
the ambien make you think racist things
that you
wouldn't normally think or did the
ambien merely lower your inhibitions to
the point where you were willing to
tweet the racist things that you always
think it's like when Mel Gibson was
pulled over that time and he was
immediately going on unprovoked
anti-semitic rants and he said the
problem was that he was drunk and of
course the question is is he saying
alcohol makes you anti-semitic or it
merely makes you willing to say the
anti-semitic things that you always
think for what it's worth the
manufacturer of ambien has put out a
statement saying that racism is not a
known side effect of ambien so so we've
heard that and I you know I don't know
is there more to say Pat about my
exchange with her or is that it is that
basically all we need to say well it's
interesting that she says that you're a
bully hours after calling Valerie
Jarrett a mix between the Planet of the
Apes and the Muslim Brotherhood I mean
can't really make that argument in that
case yeah I don't really have a
reputation for bullying people but okay
that's what she chose to say to me let's
talk about sort of the firing and the
implications here I want to put up an
assessment that is 100% a similar to
mine and it's from another none other
than Dave Rubin who at one point was
using Roseanne's studio for his show
Dave Rubin tweeted yesterday Roseanne
exercised her free speech and ABC
decided to end their free association
now it's on you to either support her or
not
boycott ABC or not or share your own
opinion as a free person or not
once again freedom is messy but it's
better than the alternative
and I agree in a sense it's not about
free speech at all and that there's no
question or concern at all about free
speech or censorship here right
Roseanne said outrageous things and her
employer fired her period she doesn't
need the money she's worth like 80
million dollars and my only real concern
is that she has really messed things up
for the entire production staff at ABC
right the people running the cameras the
people doing the tech work they don't
have 80 million dollars like Roseanne do
they lose their jobs now because of
Roseanne's racist tweet hopefully some
of those employees are part of a union
and maybe are guaranteed money for the
first season or whatever no matter
whether the show is canceled
or not hopefully I I don't really know
the answer to that
and of course Donald Trump I don't even
know that we're not gonna put it up on
the screen to Trump did say something
about how he never received a call from
Bob Iger from ABC when ABC criticized
him but Bob Iger called Valerie Jarrett
or something like that the only
surprising thing about any of this is
that anybody was surprised by it because
of Roseanne's very very long history of
tweeting bizarre and depraved conspiracy
theories and generally just insulting
things but I think it was a big win in
the battle of ideas Pat I mean listen
everybody got to say what they wanted to
say a corporation was able to make the
business decision that they felt was
right for them government didn't
interfere period right I mean a major
win in the battle of the free exchange
of ideas yeah everything worked out ok I
guess I'm just surprised ABC decided to
have her back on to reboot the sitcom
knowing that Roseanne has a history of
doing this saying racist things on
Twitter she actually made a very similar
remark about Susan Rice another former
Obama official and the other black woman
comparing hurts who will monkey as well
yes so you know they could have
preempted some of this at least it's
like it's not like this is a new thing
for moze and that's why I'm not going
around patting ABC on the back saying
wow they've they've just done this
amazing thing they made a business
decision it is a that is exactly what it
is if this were good for business if
people weren't outraged but they said
you know what it's so great that
someone's finally out there saying that
valerie jarrett is like a monkey in some
way they wouldn't have fired her right
they would have said hey Roseanne said
what she wanted to say on her Twitter we
employ her to produce the Roseanne show
or act in the Roseanne show whatever
this is merely all about optics and
you're right Pat which is that this is
not shocking this is another one in a
long history of these types of comments
from Roseanne so I think that the the
decision made by ABC was the right one
although they made it for business
decisions not from not for business
reasons not for moral or ethical reasons
and that's completely something that
they can do send me your thoughts about
the entire Roseanne thing I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
and sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership